when you said giselle getting paid in
euros gee that reminded me that people
have started to be uh you know people
have started to ask to be paid in
bitcoins i'm just going to push that
button brent i'm just going to go there
i mean it's yeah it's it's it's a
similar concept is that you know you
don't want to get paid in something at
the lows but let's be serious here it's
complete nonsense like euros are
convertible to dollars at almost zero
transaction costs bitcoin can be
converted to dollars like if you want to
get paid in bitcoin just get your
dollars and buy bitcoin it's it's just
like a pr stunt but it what it is is
people riding the bandwagon of what's
popular and that's why it's an anecdotal
indicator because if the mayor of new
york is saying i'm going to get paid in
bitcoin
you know he's not going to be doing that
at the lows right he's going to be doing
that at the highs but if he really
wanted bitcoin you know what he does is
he opens a coinbase account and buys
some bitcoin he doesn't need to get paid
in bitcoin it's just like a nonsensical
pr strategy that people use